guardians of the galaxy - is stacked
with Easter eggs new characters and
heartbreaking emotional moments but
numerous scenes and characters still
wound up on the cutting room floor
yep UK weary lovers it's Jan here and in
this video I'm going to be breaking down
a ton of incredible concept art which
features alternate designs and
characters we never got to see in
guardians volume 2 I'll also be
analyzing all the scenes and characters
that were deleted from the final curse a
quick reminder that my guardians the
galaxy giveaway is still running so be
sure to leave a comments about the movie
and subscribe for a chance to win and
I'll provide more details at the end of
the video obviously spoilers lie ahead
for guardians the galaxy vol 2 if you
haven't seen the movie yet you can tap
in the top right for my spoiler free
review and come back here after you've
seen the film in volume 2 to
differentiate mantas from Gamora James
Gunn decided not to give the new
character green skin which he often has
in the comics however various pieces of
concept art for mantas show a
green-skinned mantis was definitely
considered at one point with reds blues
purples and many other shades also
considered the antenna life a mantis in
the concept art are also a bit more
bug-like and her costumes and more
details in the final smooth costume that
mantis ended up with in fact according
to visual effects supervisor Chris
Townsend they adopted a very subtle
approach when it came to using CGI to
enhance mantis its look Townsend said
that mantis is supposed to be bug like
so we talked about larger eyes strange
mandibles and various prosthetic and we
played around with lots of different
ideas but we eventually ended up
realizing that poms performance is so
beautiful and subtle that all we really
needed to do was put the antenna on her
head and give her black irises to give
her more of a bug feeling Marvel's
visual development team for volume 2
also considered many options for the
lack of ego before settling on his final
form if uniqueness as a character meant
that everything from his human
appearance with ship and his planet
needed to all work together visual
development supervisor Andy Park says
the ideas for ego human form range with
swashbuckling pirate to gun-slinging
Cowboys a more organic earthy look in
the end they went for a space
frontiersman mixed with a little bit of
Western which seemed to fit well with
his final role in the movie sofa egos
costume designer Judy onna makovski used
many layers of different leathers that
were made
dror died to give them what she called a
sort of medieval or Renaissance detail
as the egos planet
that's home to a couple of deleted
scenes and in the first one just after
the Guardians arrived their ego shows
Peter a statue he made of star-lord and
his friends director James Gunn said it
was a really great joke but he ended up
cutting it because it didn't move the
plot along and inside egos palace there
was another cutscene where ego shifted
the appearance of the whole room in the
scene the wall panels reformed into a
type of sand mural that showed various
touching moments in Peters life such as
time he spent with his mother and scenes
of him bonding with you on doing groups
like the statue scene this was another
way for ego to show how he admired Peter
and had been taking an interest in his
son throughout his life something we
didn't get to see in the final movie was
the sovereigns and boy robots these seem
to be a kind of soldier robot which has
piloted remotely by the sovereign people
in a similar way to how they operated
their golden drones remotely when they
attack the guardians in space it's
interesting to speculate on what themes
these robots could have been involved in
perhaps for example they were part of
some backstory involving the problems
this sovereign has with the annual axe
batteries what we do know for sure about
the envoi robots however is that
according to visual development artist
Rodney Point Ivania their design mixes
the gold coloring of the sovereign race
with Anna Marsh the look of b-movie
alien robots Nathan Fillion has been a
regular in many of James Gunn's previous
films including sliver super and the
first guardians of the galaxy movie
where he voiced the monstrous inmate of
the kiln prison who threatened Peter
quill until Groot took matters into his
own hands as for guardians vol 2 there
was an extended scene set on earth that
had the Firefly star appear and what was
likely going to be a funny Easter Egg
style cameo set photos indicate there
were scenes filled with Simon Williams
film festival when Nathan Fillion
appeared as the actor Simon Williams on
posters at the festival the scene would
have been filled with Easter eggs
because Simon Williams is actually a
character from the comics he's been an
actor a super villain and a superhero
and is also known as Wonder Man on top
of that pictures of the posters from the
set suggest that the film showing a
festival going to exclusive some
well-known movies for example there was
dead before arrivals a riff on the
poster for Inception Oh Rebecca which
looks like a spoof of
rom-com Definitely Maybe which starred
Ryan Reynolds hacks and - that looks
like the poster for the Daniel Radcliffe
movie horns and Tony Stark which clearly
takes its inspiration from Danny Boyle's
biopic of Steve Jobs and during those
missing earth sequences who were going
to be a longer scene with Grandpa quill
in which according to an interview with
Collider James Gunn said there would be
even more Easter eggs from the scenes in
the collective Museum in the first
guardians movie
grandpa quill did appear very briefly in
a car pushed along by the blob but Gunn
drastically cut the earth scenes losing
most of grandpa quill plus numerous
other cameos by friends of the director
another planned cameo which sadly didn't
happen with my David Bowie during volume
tooth development both Kevin Feige and
James going to reached out to see if
they can get a cameo as a singer and at
one point it was looking hopeful going
to also secured the rights to use
another of Bowie's songs in volume 2
after having already used moonage
daydream in the first film however the
new suddenly broke that Bowie had died
which gutted Gerner he was a huge fan of
the musical legend and unfortunately the
scene in which guns lands use the Bowie
track was also cut so he never got to
hear it in the final film it was also a
major character gun initially planned to
use in volume 2 but he was removed from
the final script that character was Adam
warlock who Gunn told / film with one of
his favorite characters and was going to
be a big part of volume 2 however the
director felt there were too many
characters in the screenplay so he
decided to lose warlock instead of
deleting mantis who he spelt with more
organically part of the movie at least
we still got that lovely teeth that Adam
warlock in the end credits scene with
Aisha and if you want to find out about
the importance of Adam warlocks role in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe going
forward tap the top right of the screen
to watch a video I made all about that
there were also a few jokes teased in
trailers and promo material that didn't
make it into the final movie for example
there was a great I am Groot moment from
the trailer and the death button scene
with rockets which I was sorry not to
see in the final cut you have an atomic
bomb in your bag if anybody's gonna take
you I have to do a free
that's a really bad sign
and James Gunn also shared a funny
deleted scene of the team eating around
a campfire with Drax slurping noisily to
everyone else's disgust dude what dude
what many consider baby Groot to be a
real scene stealer and there's some
concept after the little tree that's
very likely to make you love him even
further concept artist Josh Herrmann has
released some very cute artwork
including a baby Groot crying with a
milk bottle grouped with a toy rocket
cocoon and another with the toddler
unraveling Peter Quill's awesome mixtape
vol 1 there's also some great concept
art of contracts via the icy planet
where the ravages go to party which
shows us pop the planet we didn't get to
see in the film in the artwork by Craig
sellers you can see a kind of giant love
robot submerged in a frozen lake for the
railway running through and there's also
what looked like various industrial
installations in the background and
there are also some interesting
alternative designs consider for the
look of the love bots on contracts fear
until the final design was settled on
which was inspired by Fritz Lang's film
metropolis the many tentacled obelisk
was a new monster introduced to the MCU
in volume 2 however some early designs
the creature showed the beast with feet
and multiple tails rather than tentacles
by the way inspiration for the a
ballistic seems to come from the comic
book cancerverse and if you're
interested in finding out more about
that you can tap on the top right where
I talked about it in my volume 2 Easter
Egg video the Ravager clans were united
by the end of the movie under stack are
in a nice end credits tease of a volume
stream initially stochastic antsy from
this concept art by Rodney fuentemayor
however one Sylvester Stallone was cast
in the role the filmmakers didn't want
to hide his presence under lasa
prosthetics or CGI though focus turned
instead to modifying the characters
costume rather than his face for example
Sicard
energy wings that come from his comic
book character were initially placed on
his head until it was thought this look
too strange but they're real okay
to his shoulders other members of stack
arse team include mainframe who in the
movie is basically a metalhead that
talks and is voiced by none other than
Miley Cyrus
the challenge for mainframes design was
to come up with a head that could then
plug into other robots or objects for
her to control various alternative
designs were considered for mainframes
head before settling on the final one we
see in the volume two end credits scene
the design of Martin acts the crystal
faced alien played by Michael Rosenbaum
was particularly difficult as the
reflections and refractions of the light
from the crystals caused various issues
so some smoother and differently shaped
heads were tried before settling on his
final look so the appearance of the worm
like Krueger gun wanted to ensure a
comic-book style look and the designers
kept his connection to dr. strange with
his hand gestures and use of glyphs an
alternate design for the character has
been looking more blinged up and kind of
creepier although clearly this design
didn't make it into the final film and
not content which is 5 post-credit
scenes gun nearly included a six scene
which would have featured the ravager
Geoff one of taser faces mutineers in
the final movie Geoff died when yondu's
arrow killed him while he was drinking
lots of beer however and a deleted end
credits scene Geoff was going to pop up
again when gomorrah and mantas suddenly
hear screaming on the ship they
discovered that jeff has been on the
ship all along and is mortally wounded
in the end James Gunn said the scene
felt confusing and didn't make a lot of
sense and that point was cursed during
one of the jump scenes of the night
Keith's the cronin character called
who'll be appearing in thor ragnarok
but concept art for the scene shows that
originally the designs of planet they
were fighting on was somewhat more
detailed and included huge stone heads
hands and feet in the background
I guess the planets work was simplified
in the end so we could focus on the two
fighting Cronin's in this super brief
scene now we've got to talk about that
ending in volume 2 and just how sad
yondu's heroic death was in fact that
wasn't how the movie was going to end
originally and in an interview with
Uproxx James Gunn said that he didn't
want that to be the ending and refused
to put it in for a long time and
actually if you think back to the first
guardians movie Peter was rescued after
he went into space to save Gamora from a
similar fate so could there have been a
way for rocket to rescue both Peter and
yondu in volume 2
although I was very sad to lose yondu it
felt like it was a strong move for the
film on the MCU in general indeed
Gunners defended his decision to do this
saying that we need to have real stakes
in these movies we need to lose
characters and thus everyone who sees
Marvel movies loves that by the way now
that we've seen the film did you notice
how in the very first teaser trailer gun
foreshadowed yondu's tragic death with
that shot of spacesuits for emergency or
for fun so do you think it was a good
decision for yondu to die at the end of
volume 2 and were there any deleted
scenes or characters you wish have been
left in the movie and what would you
like to see in vol 3 be sure to comment
about the movie and subscribe for a
chance to win these prizes in my
giveaway they include two awesome
hardback books from DK guardians of the
galaxy the ultimate guide to the cosmic
outlaws which takes an in-depth look at
iconic characters issues and storylines
from the comics and I've also got the
selection of three cool Guardians Funko
pop vinyl figures turn on your
notifications to get all my new videos
where I'll be announcing the winners and
if you enjoyed this video do hit that
thumbs up button and check out more of
my guardians of galaxy vol 2 and Marvel
videos right here thanks for watching
and see you next time
epic a movie lovers